[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado el día
vamos a hablar de la difícil situación
que vive en los afganos en este segundo
invierno que comienza desde que los
talibanes tomaron el poder y la
posterior congelación de los fondos
extranjeros millones están al borde de
la hambruna según Naciones Unidas el
panorama es aún más difícil para la
familias donde algunos padres incluso
han tenido que Cedar a sus hijos para
calmarles el hambre saludamos a Vicente
Raymundo Él es director de cooperación
internacional de save de children España
Gracias eficiente por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de miércoles en directo
América de Francia 24 en esta
oportunidad para tratar un tema bastante
triste no y que preocupa pues gran parte
de la comunidad internacional sobre todo
a la parte médica no este titular que
hemos visto en varios medios de
comunicación también sobre todo en la
bbc que dicen que en una ciudad de
Afganistán hay muchísimos padres han
tenido que incluso Cedar a sus hijos con
medicamentos para poder calmarles el
hambre evidentemente esto tiene
implicaciones médicas en los niños en el
hígado pues procesa evidentemente todos
los medicamentos que Nosotros tomamos y
también no sé si para el desarrollo
cognitivo pero Qué tan grave es digamos
abriendo un poco el panorama esta
situación de hambruna en Afganistán tras
la llegada de los talibanes
primero Muchas gracias por la
oportunidad que nos dais la crisis
actual en Afganistán no tiene
precedentes esa es la escala no hay una
crisis precedente con la que se la pueda
se la pueda comparar estamos ante la
peor crisis humanitaria que el país ha
sufrido desde que tiene antes de que
tiene existencia O sí una cifra que
quizás muy reveladora es que en estos
momentos en Afganistán que es un país
grande y bastante poblado solo hay un 3%
de las familias que tienen los recursos
necesarios para cubrir sus necesidades
básicas estamos hablando de comida
bebida y abrigo
Vicente también la situación preocupante
de los niños como esto afectaría el
desarrollo y digamos organizaciones como
seis de children también el programa de
alimentos de León y diferentes
organizaciones humanitarias como están
haciendo en la actualidad para trabajar
en Afganistán entendiendo evidentemente
todas las difíciles situaciones que se
han presentado tras la llegada de los
talibanes al poder no Y también
geográficamente que el país tiene zonas
muy Rurales de difícil penetración
bien en estos momentos la malnutrición
aguda que afecta a los niños menores de
6 años en Afganistán ha incrementados se
ha incrementado más de un 50% es decir
se ha Doblado desde enero de este año y
sí que es cierto que en estos momentos
hay zonas del país que no eran
accesibles por la situación de conflicto
anterior que ahora sí lo son en las
condiciones como has dicho Son son
dificilísimas tenemos el invierno que no
es un invierno digamos a la europea
incluso a la manera del norte de Europa
como podéis estar vosotros ahora es un
invierno durísimo y los recursos para
para enfrentar la situación son
escasísimos recordemos que hay unas
sanciones internacionales que afectan al
país O sea que en estos momentos no es
el conflicto lo que explica la situación
de organizar sino son años de sequía es
la cuarto quinto año y una situación de
crisis económica tremenda por eso
mencionaba antes que no tiene No tiene
precedentes y el impacto para la
infancia que son los más vulnerables
junto con las personas más ancianas son
las que más dificultades tienen
enfrentar una realidad extrema por
definición
pues es Espeluznante también Vicente
dentro de esa infancia afgana bien
vulnerada y maltratada la que estamos
hablando hay que pues lamentablemente
también que hablar de las niñas que son
las que también más sufren este tipo de
vulneraciones a sus derechos sobre todos
los derechos Pues de los infantes no y
es que algunos padres también debido a
esta difícil situación han tenido que
incluso llegar a vender a sus hijas Cómo
cómo es este tema social también como
afecta esto Pues a la familias a los
padres que han tenido que llegar a esta
situación y cómo poder rescatar digamos
estas niñas que han sido vendidas para
poder subsistir de alguna manera y no
morirse de hambre sí te agradezco mucho
esta esta pregunta porque si la crisis
desde su punto de vista humanitario en
Afganistán es terrorífica es
particularmente terrorífica para para
las niñas hay unos 8 millones de niños
en Afganistán que no no pueden Acceder
al circunstancias al colegio pero de
estos hay tres millones que eran mujeres
niñas que estaban previamente asistiendo
a la escuela secundaria que ya no pueden
asistir Porque existe una prohibición
del gobierno talibán para su acceso en
la educación en la educación secundaria
por encima del sexto del sexto grado y
en referente a Por qué las familias
recurren a esto medidas desesperadas
para tiempos desesperados y cuando uno
lo ha perdido todo no tiene nada más que
vender no tiene trabajo no tiene futuro
recurre a estas medidas que desde un
punto de vista si quieres occidental
europeo son inconcebibles pero si uno
tiene que hacer que su familia sobreviva
a familia entendía como un concepto
amplio y no tiene absolutamente nada que
vender y existe una demanda por sabiendo
que por un matrimonio recibes x o y
griegas bienes las niñas están las niñas
están vendiendo efectivamente está
viendo tráfico de tráfico y tratas
insisto es una crisis de infancia y en
general humanitaria de un tamaño que no
tiene precede en Afganistán y si quieres
otro dato y nosotros tuvimos un informe
recientemente a final del verano hicimos
una encuesta entre entre las niñas y los
niños de nuestros programas y vimos que
había diferencias significativa entre la
ratio de problemas mentales de los
varones y de las chicas las chicas casi
un 30% de ellas
te presentaban problemas mentales medios
a severos y los y los muchachos apenas
llegaba al 20%, no es una crisis
particularmente cruel con la mujer y con
las niñas increíblemente cruel la verdad
que pues a veces yo me quedo pues sin
palabras de esta conversación que
estamos teniendo y estas cifras tan
alarmantes Vicente como como el panorama
a futuro
Bueno si si si concordamos en que bueno
la panistán es un país que lleva una
situación extremadamente complicada
desde los años 70 No desde la época de
la unión soviética etcétera etcétera no
lo sabemos todos pero si concluimos
ahora mismo que tenemos los dos factores
determinantes que hacen que la báscula
haya oscilado hacia hacia el pla del
drama absoluto que son la sequía y la
crisis económica sobre la sequía en
estos momentos a corto plazo poco se
puede hacer hay cosas que se pueden
hacer a medio plazos si hay que mantener
una población viva y que pase el
invierno eso sabemos cómo hacerlo otra
cosa es tener los recursos y el acceso
pero se sabe cómo se hace y la parte de
crisis económica tiene mucho que ver con
el régimen de sanciones internacionales
de ahí que no solo set de children sino
las organizaciones internacionales en
general siempre defienden la excepción
humanitaria no somos parciales somos
neutrales no opinamos en este sentido os
tenemos claro lo que pensamos pero
tenemos que tener acceso a las víctimas
y sabemos que las víctimas son inocentes
y que necesitan recibir una atención
basada en principios humanitarios es
decir basada en necesidades y Para ello
se necesita recursos por lo tanto
pedimos lo que se llama la excepción
humanitaria que se hace en otros
contextos es decir usted sanciona Quien
tenga que sancionar pero asegúrese de
que estas sanciones no las pagan justos
por pecadores Quienes son los justos en
este caso pues clarísimamente las
personas más vulnerables la infancia
tienen que poder tienen que poder
abrirse tiene que poder asistir al
médico etcétera etcétera sancione su
responsabilidad pero nuestra
responsabilidad recordarle que estas
sanciones no pueden castigar a todo el
mundo por igual y que gente que es
inocente por definición y que es
Intocable por definición que son las
víctimas de una crisis que tienen
derecho a recibir asistencia humanitaria
neutral e Imparcial pues Vicente Ojalá
que se descongelamiento de estos
recursos pues se haga efectivo no para
organizaciones como en este caso aceite
para poder ayudar a los más vulnerables
Lamentablemente como en casi todos los
conflictos los niños son los que más
sufren